Let's talk a little bit about content workflow now.
So the topics we want to cover here are working with the assets inside of Unreal, whether
we use ready-made assets, which are Starter Pack or the Marketplace or Quixel library,
or we have custom assets that you're importing yourself via FBX or Datasmith.
And then we'll discuss the Static Mesh Editor.
So some useful hotkeys to use for your viewport navigation.
It might just help to either screenshot this screen or write them down.
Just some useful buttons here to click whilst navigating the interface.
And we'll dive into the editor as well later on as well.
So the content workflow, we have starter content, which on the bottom left-hand
side here you can see that when you select some of the project templates,
in the bottom right-hand side you'll see starter content tick box.
So that will include any content that you might want to use by default for your scenes,
just to edit content, move them around, manipulate them in your own way.
But it just gives you a library of assets to start with there.
We also have the Marketplace, which we referred to on previous slides.
On the top right-hand side here, we have the Marketplace tab on the launcher,
where you can find different files and templates to add to your own projects.
If you see anything on there that you want to add,
you can just click the button add to project.
You might have to purchase it first, but there's a lot of free content on there as well.
And they're easily integrated into your projects.
And it's worth noting that even if you've already got a project
and you may want to add some Marketplace content to that,
you can always add it to the project after the fact.
So you can always add more content if need be.
The Quixel library is accessed through the editor as well.
And you can see this on the bottom right-hand side.
And there's lots of information on Quixel and lots of great assets to download,
all high-quality assets and free to use for Unreal Engine users.
And we can also migrate assets from one project to another.
So it's worth noting that maybe you have some content
you've got in one project that you want to move to another project.
We can actually migrate this information from one project to the next.
And I'll show you how to do that in a few slides as well.
So before you export your DCC or your CAD app,
we want to make sure we're using descriptive names for the objects and materials.
So make sure everything is named what it should be.
Make sure they're not just, you know, a geometry shape underscore 01
or any default name and just objects or something like this.
Make sure you have everything named correctly
and the materials assigned how you intend them to be inside of Unreal.
You want to make sure the scene is well organized
and combine any meshes together that you don't need all individualized.
You want to make sure your meshes are clean and consistent with proper UV layout.
You also want to pay attention to objects that have been scaled.
So you want to make sure that everything is just a scale of 111.
And especially so for non-uniform geometry as well.
So ideally everything's coming into the editor at a scale of 111,
which is your scale and your transform and your rotation in a world zero essentially.
And we want to make sure the scenes, if they're not at world zero,
just move them as close to world zero as you can
because the further out you get, we get some rounding errors happening.
So just yeah, X, Y, and Z zeroed out there and then reset pivot points
and ensure they're in the right place.
So you can actually reset the pivot points in Unreal Engine.
And there is a tool to do that.
However, it's always good just best practice,
have your assets in the stage that you want them to be at
when they come into Unreal Engine.
You can make edits and manipulate the content inside of Unreal Engine,
but it's best to have them from your DCC app or CAD app
as you intend them to be from the get-go.
So which world to take?
We can use either FBX or Datasmith.
So with the FBX exporter, you manage your system units
if you are planning to use FBX workflows.
We use centimeters as a base unit to match on Unreal Engine system.
So in your DCC app, just make sure your units are set up in centimeters
and make sure your objects are centered to the world
and that their pivot is zero zero as we mentioned before.
However, with Datasmith, first of all,
you need to make sure you have the exporter for your DCC of choice.
So there's a hyperlink here which you can go to the website
and it has the exporters for 3ds Max or SketchUp
or whatever DCC app you're using.
So you don't need to worry as much about the scene units here
because the Datasmith converter takes care of everything
and it also reads and imports your CAD formats natively.
It works well with fully assembled scenes and large data sets.
It's also compatible with more material types that FBX can provide
and you can export full scenes or partial ones.
The simple exporter in the UI can also default to what is only visible on the screen.